we're hearing from victims of one of the
country's most notorious and bizarre
mass kidnappings 43 years ago
20:26 California children and their
driver were taken from a school bus and
buried alive one of the three kidnappers
has a parole hearing this morning the
abductions took place in the central
California city of Chowchilla our lead
national correspondent David Beck know
is looking into the case for 48 hours
David the facts of this case if you
hadn't heard about it before still
chilling
look it's terrifying right imagine this
right so little kids on the school bus
with their driver during the summer
they're on their way home in the middle
of nowhere and they just vanished like
vanished without a trace
and so there's been a parole hearing you
know nearly every three years for the
last 40 or so and can you imagine the
trauma for people who are now adults who
were still reliving what happened to
them when they were just children
I was wondering how it was gonna feel to
die I was too scared to move it was 1976
26 terrified children some as young as
five and their school bus driver Edie
ray were kidnapped at gunpoint by three
armed men the first man came on the bus
and he had a gun ed ray said what's
going on and he said shut up and moved
to the back the kidnappers who plan to
ask for a five million dollar ransom
drove the kids to a rock quarry where a
truck trailer had been hidden
underground about 12 feet they forced
the children inside through a hole in
the roof and buried them alive and I
felt like I was an animal going to the
slaughterhouse it would be silent and
then somebody would bust out crying and
oh well just you rock after about 12
hours the roof started to cave in and I
remember children just screaming and
crying the sides of the van were bowing
in I knew that I was going to die I knew
it they were able to escape digging
their way out and getting to safety but
those 28 hours of terror would impact
the rest of their lives by the time I
was 21
I was using math I was smoking crack
when you've gone through something
that's so traumatic it's hard to go back
and be a normal kid again it has now
been 43 years and those survivors are
still piecing their lives back together
I have nine year sober my resentment for
them was killing me one night I was
laying in bed and I said god help me
to forgive them and forgive he did that
was Larry Park Larry met with one of the
kidnappers Richard Schoenfeld and he
said it changed his life that he was
finally at peace when that happened
Richard and his brother James were both
paroled within the last seven years
the third kidnapper alleged mastermind
Frederic woods
his latest parole hearing is today in
California David I have so many
questions here and I know you're gonna
get a lot of media on the show on
Saturday but so why is woods in prison
but the show into the brothers are out
so he was caught with pornography and a
cell phone and he wasn't a model
prisoner for the last many decades and
today what I can tell you is this there
will be evidence put forward that he
still has not been a model prisoner it's
interesting to see the trauma that still
stays with him 43 years later I was so
vivid yes so I was in college I remember
because it was so eerie you'd never
heard anything like that but to see the
pictures of them David his little kids
and then to segue to them as adults you
can still see their little faces in the
hour on Saturday night gale when you
listen to people like Larry and others
like Mike Marshall um their lives
literally fell apart I mean this
happened to them it's such an innocent
age and for the last 40 years they have
just struggled you know to get through
life the past is still entirely present
for the absolutely and imagine a pearl
they're been within 60 parole hearings
in the last 40 years No all right David
thank you very much